today the mat well show AI pornography
is spreading like wildfire on the
internet what are the dangers of this
technology and where does this all lead
we'll discuss also a strange object is
hovering in our skies it's not aliens or
so they claim but a Chinese spy balloon
so why hasn't the bite Administration
shut it down by now AOC puts on her most
over-the-top acting performance yet NBC
News publishes yet another lengthy hit
piece on me in the daily wire an alleged
conservative publication suggests that
we should find a middle ground in the
war over gender ideology but does any
Middle Ground exist in our daily
cancellation we tackle the subject of no
fault divorce all of that and more today
on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
the past couple of years have taught us
anything it's that in a crisis like a
global pandemic or a natural disaster
even the basics can be hard to come by
you need to be prepared for anything and
that's what my new partners at Jace
medical are all about it and they're
here to help Jace medical helps you get
a long-term supply of prescription
medication their mission is to empower
you to be better medically prepared a
great way to start preparing is with the
Jace case a pack of five different
courses of antibiotics that you can use
to treat a whole host of bacterial
illnesses including UTIs respiratory
infections sinuses skin infections and
more all you have to do is fill out a
simple online form and in some cases
jump on a quick call with one of their
board certified Physicians and from
there you could ask your physician
treatment related questions on an
ongoing basis and so you'll have that
you'll have that that help as well this
is so important to do especially if you
have a kids you know you have a bunch of
kids in the house like I do and you
never know what kinds of emergencies if
it's not a National Emergency you never
know what kind of emergencies you'll be
dealing with and uh that's why the Jace
case gives me peace of mind knowing that
my family we will have what we need if
the worst happens and I want you to be
prepared for anything as well go to
jacemedical.com enter code wall should
check out for a discount on your order
that's jacemedical.com promo code Welsh
well we truly live in A Brave New World
well not really Brave anyway but it is
new I guess and it's new in ways that
threaten to make obsolete that old adage
that there's nothing new Under the Sun
because in our day and age we have many
we have managed to create some new
things I think things without precedent
things without historical analog
um the problem is that nearly all of
those things are well terrible take for
example the burgeoning industry of AI
pornography this is porn generated by
artificial intelligence it encompasses
both deep fake porn which is fashion to
look like some actual specific human
being and then totally artificial porn
whose images are created entirely by a
machine
um there's been a lot of discussion
about the subject this past week due to
a controversy in the world of twitch
streamers this is a world that remains
mostly foreign to me and perhaps to you
but I think we can both get the gist
from this write-up in Vice it says quote
on Monday twitch streamer Brandon Ewing
who goes by atriac online
admitted to buying and watching deep
fakes from an account that makes
non-consensual sexually explicit AI
generated videos of his colleagues in
the streaming World in a live stream on
Monday Ewing inadvertently showed
browser windows open to a website that
hosts non-consensual AI generated images
the window showed that he was viewing
images on the account of someone who
specialized in making deep fakes of
popular streamers viewers of the stream
caught the leak and screenshotted the
site and shared the site images from it
and names of the women who were deep
faked at first reported by Dextero Ewing
said during his Monday stream in a
tearful now viral apology that he
clicked an ad for deep fake porn while
browsing PornHub that ad took him to
another subscriber only website that he
said were paid to view the images of
popular female streamers he said that he
was driven by morbid curiosity that his
watching non-consensual porn is not a
pattern of behavior
his wife cosplayer Ariana Ewing I don't
know what any of these words mean sat in
the background of the stream and cried
uh
here's some of whatever that is
stream to like create a pattern of
behavior where I really want especially
women on Twitter to feel safer like I uh
we call buba spam cringe we don't do
that there I've never made like a
weird I don't know see sniffing joke
I've never done anything like that I've
never done anything like that on a
stream and we don't tolerate any sex
behavior in the chat we banned it on
site
and uh and like I've done this
consistently over and over and over and
then at 2 am
you know I've been watching so much I've
been reading so much AI stuff uh
reading all this stuff about Ai and and
uh
defect music defect guard and everything
and I'm in these discords and I was I
feel so embarrassing to me but I was on
website and there was an ad there's an
ad on every video for this so I know
other people must be clicking it because
it's on every video
now to me the I the the real problem one
of the real problems here is that this
guy is a professional I mean he's a
professional broadcaster this is what
qualifies as professional broadcasters
these days he has a large audience
people who sit around and watch him and
listen to him and yet he's incapable of
stringing three words together without
an F-bomb I mean he has the rhetorical
skill of like a college freshman it just
downed three beer bongs and yet he has
320 000 followers on a streaming
platform
that to me is uh the issue or it's an
issue the bigger problem of course is
the AR I AI porn itself and some have
made an attempt to defend this guy
claiming that well he isn't hurting
anyone by watching deep fake porn
but of course any rational and uh even
just nominally decent person understands
that using someone's image without their
permission using their face their
likeness to create pornography is a
moral Abomination and consuming such
pornography knowing how it was created
is also morally abominable yet whether
deep fakes or other forms of AI point
the trend is becoming so prevalent so
fast that internet platforms are
scrambling to figure out how to handle
all this this is uh just a couple weeks
ago in the New York Post this article
says the internet group that creates
pornographic images using artificial
intelligence was kicked off fundraising
platforms Kickstarter and patreon after
raising nearly sixty thousand dollars
following complaints from social media
users unstable diffusion describes
itself as an online community of artists
dedicated to creation and sharing of AI
generated NSFW not suitable for word
content
um the group uses open source text image
generating systems that were popularized
by online groups such as stable
diffusion and dance diffusion last year
the AI powered technology doll e which
generates digital images from text
descriptions took the Internet by storm
um quote unstable diffusion is a group
dedicated to spreading free and
expressive AI usage born out of a
Grassroots Community effort to reject
the limiting rules of corporate AI
companies the group says on its website
AI porn has become it's become a point
of debate on Twitter as well this week
where an image of four blonde women went
viral because people were
arguing about whether the image was AI
or not
um here's a photo it's a blurred photo
because women are mostly naked but here
it is and I I think that this is AI
based on the fact that the faces all
look creepily the same but the fact that
we can't tell for sure
that there's any debate about whether
the women in that image actually exist
is precisely what makes this so
terrifying because we are rapidly
getting to a point
we've already reached the point probably
where you simply cannot be sure whether
an image a voice even a video that you
watch is real or not even if it features
someone who you know exists
that doesn't mean that it actually is
real
this new reality or unreality has
far-reaching implications that I don't
think I don't think we've even begun to
scratch the surface of but those
implications are perhaps the most
disturbing in this realm in the realm of
porn
um now some real Flesh and Blood
internet prostitutes like only fans
model Laura Lux have spoken out about
the possibility that the entire porn and
cyber prostitution industry will soon
come crashing down as the people in that
field can all now be replaced by
artificial intelligence uh luck says
that she's not worried about that
however because as she tweeted quote
anyone who thinks AI generated images of
hot naked women is going to ruin the
only fans economy for real life women
has a fundamental misunderstanding of
what only fans is people don't subscribe
to my only fans because they want to see
a random naked woman they subscribe to
my only fans because they want to see me
naked specifically based on a parasocial
connection form by following me on other
social media platforms
now I'm not really
I confess concerned about the job
security of only fans prostitutes when I
mentioned the horrific implications of
this technology that's not exactly what
I was talking about in fact if anything
putting porn stars out of work is maybe
the one single benefit of this
technology because at least it might
Force these women's to to these women to
do something productive and valuable
with their lives instead
and
I do think that day is coming because
despite the um the reassurance Miss Lux
offers to us but really to herself
there's a reality here which is that you
know she's correct that only fans
customers
are looking for something that resembles
a human connection human affection
Romance
it's just that the porn consumer has
given up on finding the genuine thing
and instead settles for its digital
imitation
that's precisely the problem for Miss
Lux they've already decided to Forfeit
genuine human Connections in favor of an
image on a screen they choose you as the
only fans model because you're not real
to them
you're not human to them you you are
accessible you are usable reusable you
are an object that they can make use of
and then discard until they want you
again you are a masturbatory aide you
are to them
nothing but a collection of body parts
you're not a human being to them you you
have been dehumanized and you are taking
part in your own dehumanization
you might as well already be a robot
which means that you can easily be
replaced by robot and as far as the porn
consumer is concerned nothing at all
would be lost
that's the harsh truth
and this is the fear with AI opponents
it's the same fear with regular porn
actually only accelerated once
artificial intelligence is added into
the mix
because increasingly people are
rejecting
human connection Human Relationships
human romance and all that traditionally
comes with it including marriage and
family in favor of images on a screen
and this is dehumanizing not just to the
person on the screen unless that person
is already not human but also
dehumanizing to the consumer
and that's also why our criticism of
um of the porn industry cannot focus
just on the fact that the porn industry
is fueled by sex trafficking for example
and that is a major problem it's not the
only problem with porn just as our
criticism of AI porn cannot focus just
on the fact that people are often being
used in deep fakes without their consent
that's a major problem with that
technology but it's not the only problem
with it
in both cases we cannot neglect to
acknowledge
the harm that's also done to the
consumer
as the consumer the viewer is driven
further into self-isolation
cut off from meaningful relationships
and destroying the ones that he already
has
while spending his time ingesting
depraved filth
he is uh lessened by it made into a
smaller
less happy less interesting less
productive all around less impressive
and fulfilled person
and now with AI adding fuel to the fire
the situation is only going to go from
bad to worse
unless we do something about it
now let's get to our headlines
so there's the uh big story people are
buzzing about today the Washington Post
a Chinese surveillance balloon is
collecting intelligence over the
continental United States right now U.S
officials disclosed on Thursday
acknowledging that the Pentagon has been
monitoring the craft for several days
and briefly considered shooting it down
before concluding that doing so posed a
safety risk
the balloon is traveling at an altitude
well above commercial air traffic and
does not present a military or physical
threat to people on the ground this
according to Brigadier General Patrick
Ryder a pentagon spokesman who told the
reporters in a hastily arranged news
conference where he addressed the
ongoing situation
the North American Aerospace Defense
command NORAD continues to track the
balloons course but officials would not
specify its present whereabouts the
Striking development comes at a time of
peak tension between the world powers
and uh just hours ahead of Secretary of
State Anthony blinken's expected
departure to Beijing where he's to hold
a series of long-scheduled meetings with
senior Chinese officials
uh maybe he'll at least bring this up to
them hey gee uh folks would you would
you mind not putting spy balloons right
over our country would you not have mine
would you mind not having spy balloons
right in our airspace
I mean it is incredibly pathetic that uh
well there's a couple things first of
all
there's no reason to believe
anything that we're told about this
story okay there's no reason to believe
anything we're told about anything these
days from
uh the administration or the corporate
media but especially in a story like
this where there's some kind of strange
thing hovering in the sky and they tell
us that it's a Chinese Bible maybe it is
but there's no reason especially to
believe that
assuming that it's a Chinese Bible
well then that does raise the question
of why wasn't this thing shot down
immediately
I was just looking uh someone had a map
showing the the alleged trajectory of
this balloon and it it uh it was
floating over Alaska before it made it
down into the continental United States
and then over Montana
you're telling me you couldn't shoot it
down over Alaska without worrying about
casualties on the ground because that's
the excuse they're giving us well if we
shoot it down then uh you'll have a
debris field and people might get her
you're talking some at some point from
Alaska to Montana
you you could not have selected a time
when it was above an area that's not
heavily populated
most of
the entire state of Alaska and all the
way down to Montana
that along that entire path
you're not you're probably not going to
hit any densely populated areas at all
Montana itself is not especially densely
populated
and they're telling us that they can't
shoot it down
it is just the perfect image of this
ineffectual impotent Administration that
there is according to them
a a
you know a spy vehicle hovering above
our country
and we're just sitting there it's like
well we don't just do about it it's a
balloon
it's not like it's going so fast that we
can't it's a balloon it's just it's just
sitting there
and we have the entire federal
government sitting around debating what
should we do about this thing I don't
know
maybe we should shoot it down
is it too late to shoot it down
and I'll tell you the other thing that
annoys me about this story okay
um is that this is a story
about a mysterious object floating in
the sky
and so far as I can tell nobody has even
brought up the possibility that it might
be aliens no one's even talking about
that
okay this is it's it's a story about it
an unidentified craft
hovering in the sky and I'm looking at
all the buzz about it on social media
and there's no one has even spent there
are no conspiracy theories involving
alien technology involved in this
discussion
is this is this who we've become as a
society I don't even recognize this
anymore
so if no one else is going to bring up
that possibility then I will at least
that's the I'd say like maybe it's
aliens maybe that's why they don't shoot
it down
why would aliens
be flying around in a balloon how will
they even get here in a balloon I mean I
don't have answers to those questions
but they are questions
they're valid ones
now for the the other latest drama in in
DC that nobody outside DC actually cares
about ilhan Omar was booted from the
Foreign Affairs committee and
the reason that she was booted from the
committee and there's been it's just
like Eric swalwell was kicked off of his
committee and um
you know because he slept with a Chinese
spy and there's been a few other
Democrats that have lost their committee
assignments and this has been a big
story in the DC media uh once again
nobody outside of that bubble cares at
all
but the reason that we're given for her
being ousted from the Foreign Affairs
committee is that she has made
anti-semitic comments in the past
and don't get me wrong that's a fine
reason to kick her off the committee but
uh I would I'd prefer if they kicked her
off
because she's just sort of generally
anti-American and shows no loyalty to or
love for the country that that took her
in and gave her a life
and made her successful and all of that
she came here as a refugee we brought
her in took her in
and um she has shown no gratitude at all
and is bitter and resentful to the
country that saved her life
so I would like to kick her off for that
reason
I mean whatever the reason is it's fine
but uh to me that's the reason
AOC feels differently though
um she's very upset that her friend
Johan Omar lost the committee assignment
she wants the rest of us to be upset
about it and here she is doing her best
black preacher impression on the the
house floor as she discusses this watch
don't tell me that this is about an ABS
a condemnation of anti-semitic remarks
when you have a member of the Republican
caucus who has talked about Jewish based
lasers and an entire amount of tropes
and also elevated her to some of the
highest committee assignments in this
body this is about targeting women of
color in the in the United States of
America don't tell me because I didn't
get a single a time my life would
threatened thank you
you have to understand these are all
performers okay she's uh AOC obviously
as a performer
um I've seen some people describe her as
a theater kid you know in in high school
that's and that is what she is and
that's
you know Congress is full of people like
this
who are simply performers and I know you
might say that
that's always been the case with
politics politics is always attracted uh
performers it's always attracted it's
always attracted people who were too
ugly to be actors
um and so they end up becoming
they end up becoming politicians and I
think that's a pretty good theory for
why people end up becoming politicians
many of them anyway because they really
what they want to be doing they want to
do is they want to be actors and they
want to be in Hollywood but they're too
ugly for that and so they end up doing
this and uh and that's true and to a
certain extent that's always been the
case in politics even before Hollywood
and movies existed
but the difference now is that there is
the opportunity to perform all the time
because of 24-hour cable news because of
the internet and social media and
they're always going for that Viral
moment that's what she was doing right
there
waving her hand around doing this whole
all the theatrics and everything
uh
and she knows that she can do that and
anytime she does it'll it can go viral
online which it did
so while politics is always attracted
these empty performer types
the problem is now that they can perform
all the time the cameras are always on
them 24 7. and so there's always this
invitation to perform
and then you end up with people like
AOC here's an article in NBC News I I
found myself in fact my own picture in
one of the top headlines in NBC News
yesterday but not because not for
anything good not because they wanted to
congratulate me or say hey nice job or I
don't know wish me well with the new
babies or anything like that instead
it's this here's the headline
how Tennessee axed millions in HIV funds
amid scrutiny from far-right
provocateurs
and the article goes on Tennessee's
recent decision to reject over 8 million
dollars in federal funds to combat HIV
was motivated at least in part by
right-wing provocateurs stoking
anti-lgbtq sentiment according to four
sources within the State Health
Department the move by Republican
Governor Bill Lee will hamstring if not
efforts to combat one of the
country's most poorly controlled
epidemics of the virus HIV Advocates say
the announce the announcement followed a
political crisis in Tennessee that began
in September when conservative media
personalities including Matt Walsh and
Ben Shapiro launched attacks on
Vanderbilt University Medical Center
over its care of transgender miners
which they alleged was barbaric in
October the pressure wound its way to
the unit that combats HIV sexually
transmitted infections and viral
hepatitis at the Tennessee Health
Department on October 21st fourth the
units director Dr Pamela Talley told
employees that because of the social
media Firestorm over Vanderbilt
information about the Tennessee
transgender task force and other trans
resources had been scrubbed from the
department's website
a leading voice in the rights opposition
to the treatment of gender dysphoria in
minors Matt Walsh a columnist from the
conservative media Outlet daily wire
published a series of widely read tweets
on September 20th targeting Vanderbilt
University Medical Center's treatment of
minors at its transgender Health Clinic
quote they now castrate sterilize and
mutilate minors as well as adults well
the next day Walsh appeared on
Tucker Carlson's Fox News show to
publicize his investigation and Ben
Shapiro a conservative commentator who
co-founded daily wire further Amplified
Walsh's attacks on Vanderbilt on his
YouTube channel and podcast decrying the
quote nonsense garbage that a boy could
be a girl and a girl can be a boy
now
uh I'm reading through this whole thing
and
they use my picture again at the top of
the article and on their home page it
was right there
uh Tennessee getting rid of HIV funds
and then the picture of me is actually a
pretty good picture though I'll give
them that I was I was uh
I appreciate that much at least
but then the interesting thing was I
have I have nothing to do with this HIV
funds thing
um so this is a story about HIV funds
being taken away I guess and they make
me the centerpiece of this story and
they put my picture there
the first I heard about this is in the
article
so the first I heard about me apparently
being involved in pulling HIV funds was
in the article about it which is always
a strange thing it's always it's a
strange day when you find out on NBC
that you were involved in a conspiracy
to deprive people of HIV treatment
because I had no idea that I'd done that
because I didn't
um but at least they acknowledge my work
against child mutilation and that's
that's really what this is about
obviously
um
what they're actually upset about and
the guy tried to remember his name I
don't have the article pulled up right
in front of me Benjamin Ryan's name
Benjamin Ryan he's uh he's obsessed he's
writing articles about me all the time
he's uh constantly tweeting things and
everything and he's he's a spec he's
very very upset that uh myself and the
daily wire that we're you know engaged
in this campaign to protect children
from being mutilated he's really upset
about that
um and but he he knows that he can't
you can't engage with us on that issue
directly because he'll lose
what he's not going to attempt to do
what none of these people will actually
attempt to do is stand up and say yes I
think it is a good idea it is the right
thing to chop the breasts off of a 15
year old to a physically healthy 15 year
old girl I think that's a good idea and
here I will tell you why none of these
people will do that because they know
they can't
at some level and not even that deep
down they know that this is a horrifying
grotesque practice
and that there's no way for them to
defend it without sounding like absolute
lunatics and so instead they constantly
look for workarounds they look for
indirect ways and usually it's uh it's
they're going to be stories about how
these reports that we're putting out and
the work that we're doing is uh is
causing death threats and bomb threats
and putting people's lives at risk
and you notice that even in those
articles
even if it were true that we were
responsible for uh you know saying
things that were that were encouraging
bomb threats and death threats which we
aren't
but even if even if that was the case
well you still haven't explained how
we're wrong about what we're saying
because they can't explain them
and this is probably the most desperate
attempt at all of all as he as he goes
you know for this for this really
desperate work around where he's trying
to tie this all into HIV funds and
whatever else
on a similar topic here this is a the
bulwark
just put out this article with this
headline Trump's escalation in the
gender War
even as the former president tries to
energize his tired campaign by pushing
on trans issues is a window opening for
a moderate approach
this is something you can always count
on alleged conservatives especially the
ones that write for the bulwark
to come along and uh and start talking
about well we need a more moderate
approach especially
when the right is winning
okay and we're being effective
and we're achieving actual wins on the
battlefield we're putting points on the
scoreboard
that's when we can always count on
people from the bulwark and other
similar republications to come along and
say let's dial it back a little bit this
is too effective you're winning a little
bit too much let's dial it back
find a moderate approach
let's find a moderate approach between
mutilating children and not mutilating
them what's the I'm sure there's Middle
Ground we can agree on
so this is an article from Gisele
Donnelly I'll read a little bit of it
it says two months into the lackluster
start of his 2024 presidential bid
Donald Trump rolled out the most
reliable weapon in the Maga Arsenal a
full-scale attack on transgender
Americans and a medical and therapeutic
communities that care for them in a
three and a half minute video screed
which we played some of it on the show
yesterday first posted on his truth
social platform Trump announced an
onslaught of gender War measures going
far beyond the questions raised in
recent years about bathroom use
transmission participation in women's
sports or the prescription of puberty
blockers or hormones for adolescents on
day one vowed Trump I will revoke Joe
Biden's policies on so-called gender
affirming care ridiculous
on the right gender affirming care has
become synonymous with premature
prescriptions of cross-sex hormones
puberty blockers and surgeries in
reality it is the common language phrase
that marks a Kinder gentler approach to
what is now known as gender dysphoria as
opposed to previous treatments for
gender identity disorder
Trump announced that he would ask
Congress to pass legislation that
recognizes only two genders male and
female that they're assigned at Birth he
vowed that he would sign a new executive
order instructing evil Federer every
Federal agency to cease all programs
that promote the concept of sex or
gender transition at any age and to ask
Congress to Outlaw the use of federal
funds to pay for transition procedures
by the way just a sidebar here a couple
things uh good and bad from from what
Trump said
bad part
and and I know this seems like splitting
hairs
um I think yeah yes we want Congress to
recognize we want we want the government
at every level to recognize the reality
of male and female that they're only two
sexes uh we we need this to be
officially recognized now it should we
shouldn't need to officially recognize
it it shouldn't be an issue but it is
and so so yes that's what we want but we
don't want Congress or any other
government body
to recognize sex quote assigned at Birth
that is certainly not the language we
want because sex is if when you say
assigned at Birth you are already
agreeing with the ideologues because you
are set you are agreeing that sex is the
kind of thing that can be assigned
and that this assignment happens
sometime after the conception of the
person
in the womb uh no sex is not a sign of
birth it is observed at Birth it is
noted at Birth it is you know it is
present at birth whatever you want to
say although it's present before birth
too
but on the positive side
um and this is something that other
people have noted and on the left they
note it with with great alarm
is that when Trump was talking about
this he is not only referring to the uh
the trans agenda as it targets kids
he's also referring to he's referring to
the entire thing I mean he's referring
to transgenderism as a concept
which is exactly what we need to be
doing
and yes ultimately
we need to be protecting both children
and adults
from this from these barbaric procedures
it makes sense to as we're doing to
start with protecting kids uh they need
our protection the most
but I don't think it should end there
as I've always said it should not be
legal for doctors to do this to anyone
I don't care how old you are
if somebody is confused about their
identity
a doctor saying okay well we'll uh you
know we'll we'll chop your penis off
we'll chop your breasts off we'll start
chopping parts of your body off until
you feel better about yourself that is
barbaric and insane and abusive no
matter how old the person is doesn't
matter magically become ethical for the
doctor because the person's over the age
of 18.
um
so I think Trump is noting that which is
good anyway back to the bulwark article
uh says whether this ploys enough to
help Revitalize Trump's presidential
effort is difficult to assess the
Republican bench is deep with aggressive
culture Warriors and Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis Trump's top rival has until
now dominated the lineup but now that
Trump has spoken what Maga candidate
will want to be seen to be more moderate
than he on transgender issues
and I'm just scrolling along here to get
to the end uh
because what I'm trying to figure out
this what's allegedly being pitched here
is a moderate position
is that we don't want the extremes of
one side or the extremes of the other
well what is the moderate position
exactly
to the degree that this sort of
radicalism has become the face of the
movement for preserving citizenship
Liberties for gay lesbian bisexual and
trans Americans it's hardly a wonder
that it provokes an ugly reaction okay
so now this person's talking about the
extremism on the other side saying
that's no good
um
but then I I scroll along I get to the
bottom
when I began to transition it was not
that long oh this person is trans trans
so that's no surprise it seemed possible
to hope that at some point that would
not be the thing that defined me I
wanted reassimilation into mainstream
Society not Revolution against it I
thought that the trans Rights Movement
would take the path charted by the
marriage equality movement the road to
normality is now blocked from both left
and right but perhaps a middle way can
be cleared Okay so
if this whole article is written it's in
the bulwark and uh you read it
it's proposing a middleweight a
compromised a compromised position and
you read the entire thing and you get to
the end and it never even stipulates
what the moderate approach is it never
suggests what what is the moderate
position
you've got one side that says uh
you know gender is fluid there are a
million of them and there's a countless
numbers on them biological sex is
essentially imaginary uh there is there
is no like objective reality when it
comes to sex and uh if a if a 12 year
old child's boy says that he's a girl
then he should be chemically castrated
like that's what one side says
then you've got the other side saying no
absolutely not to all of that
and then you've got this person saying
let's uh well what about in the middle
okay what is the middle between those
two positions
and the reason why they never stipulate
the middle ground is because there isn't
one
it doesn't exist
okay you cannot have a middle ground
between
horrific falsehoods on one side from the
gender ideology crowd and the truth on
the other side
because that's all you're getting from
the other side it's just the truth
they're only males and females sex is
binary you shouldn't mutilate kids you
shouldn't mutilate anyone this is this
is our position and it is scientifically
true it's morally true
so you've got falsehood and Truth any
kind of Middle Ground here's why there's
no middle ground
because
if you stray even one inch from the
truth and towards the falsehood
well now it's a falsehood now now we're
just like degrees there's the truth and
then there's the falsehood it's not a
spectrum it's not like there's a
spectrum where you go along and like
suddenly the the falsehood kind of
blends with the truth and right there in
the middle is the sweet lukewarm spot no
it's it's uh there are many different
like versions of falsehoods some more
extreme than others and then there's the
truth
and if you venture away from the truth
then you are in the realm of falsehood
that's not a compromise that is a
surrender
and it's a surrender of something that
we absolutely cannot surrender
right um
this is maybe Biden's finest moment
we've heard a lot of uh alleged gaffes
from Biden but this one I really
appreciate it listen
s more than half the women in my cabinet
more than more than half the people in
my cabin more than half of the women in
my Administration are women
what I what I love about that is that he
he does correct himself but then he goes
back to the wrong way
because he says more than half the women
I mean more than half the people know
more than half the women are women
so he he caught himself but then he then
he went back to the wrong way of saying
more than half the women in his
administration are women
which people assume that that's a gaff
and he's just stumbling over his words
because he's senile and of course that's
usually the case but in this
Administration
there may be some reality to that
no half half of the women in our in the
administration are actually are women
the other half of the women are men I
guess is what he's trying to say
all right let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
[Applause]
as members of the SPG you're well
acquainted with my Affinity for pop
culture and uh old school hip-hop you
know about this as well as the
undeniable street cred that I've
garnered through my life as an
accomplished gang leader as a true rap
Mogul all I could ever ask is to make my
greatest influences and Hip-Hop role
models who sheisty and spot em got em
and Takashi 69 proud that being said I'm
proud to announce the newest sweet baby
album t-shirt which is uh we unveiled
yesterday and it is the notorious SBG
this latest addition to my swag Shack is
available now at dailywire.com shop and
uh we just keep we keep putting I mean
there are so many great things on on the
shop if you haven't been in swag track
recently this shirt is great
but uh we have so many other great
things there and you can celebrate my
long established roots in hip-hop world
with yet another instant classic if we
sell enough of these it's uh not
complete out of the question that I they
want me to say they want me to again
promise that I'm gonna freestyle rap for
you if we sell enough of these and I
will not make that promise I'm not going
to even talk about that because then
that'll be my life the next six months
will be people harassing me hey Matt
when are you gonna do the freestyle
reference so I won't do that but if you
buy a lot of these shirts I will give
you a hearty thank you
if you buy a lot of them
if you don't you can go to hell go to
dailywire.com shop to get your notorious
SPG t-shirt today
well for our comment section today we
must unfortunately once again move away
from responding to comments from the SPG
so that I can instead defend the
validity and dignity and honor of the
SBG itself
and especially of myself your trusted
cult leader as you know Candace Owens my
colleague and a parent sworn Enemy at
the daily wire has launched a campaign
to overtake the sweet baby gang uh she
wants to come up with her own gang all
with the intention of supplanting the
SPG as the daily wires preeminent and
most prestigious cult
um and she's even solicited suggestions
for gang names but all the suggestions
were corny as hell and didn't come close
to capturing the spontaneous
poetic charm of the sweet baby gang
so so far this campaign is off to a
rather pitiful start but now she's
taking it a step further and she's even
now Enlisted the help of AI voice
generating software speaking of AI stuff
which has um this has not turned into
like an information War I guess and this
is from her show watch
you know Matt's Walsh my colleague my
non-friend my arch nemesis Matt Walsh
you know he's got that sweet baby gang
and I would like to have the sweet baby
gang and guess what guys Matt Walsh
agrees that it's mine let's hear Matt
Walsh maybe not but definitely do say
that the sweet babe sweet baby gang is
mine
today on the Matt Walsh show I'll be
telling you why I'm formally stepping
down as the leader of the sweet baby
gang I've searched long and hard for a
successor and have finally found one she
is the host of my favorite podcast ever
and has the best taste in bottled water
first I have to admit that I was wrong
Dasani is absolute trash secondly I am
announcing that I am formally handing
control of the sweet baby gang to my
dear friend Candace Owens
I mean is that not incredible and
terrifying but also amazing that Matt
Walsh has renounced himself as the
leader of the soup baby gang that's
actually mine he admits that I'm his
dear friend and also admits that I'm
right about how disgusting asani water
is all that actually happened or did it
happen did he actually say that was that
from Matt Walsh's podcast
okay
first I I am glad to find out that uh
for Candace Owens her greatest dream in
her career is to be my successor so I do
appreciate that second I never said that
Dasani water is good bottled water I
said that it's just it's it's bottled
water and that's all it is and it tastes
like every other bottle of water and I
proved that beyond a shadow of a doubt
in a blind taste test that we did in her
show which I won
third I might not be as concerned about
AI technology now as I was at the
beginning of the show because that did
not impress me at all that didn't sound
like me in the slightest bit
um
wasn't even slightly convincing I mean
that that robot could never capture the
soul and gravity of my voice I I have
the voice I've been told of
like it in ill-tempered
grizzly bear who smokes too many
cigarettes and I take that as a
compliment I don't know if it's intended
that way that's how I take it and the AI
didn't come close to that also by the
way she she began that segment
um by announcing ahead of time that the
clip was was made using AI
which kind of defeats the purpose of the
bit when you tell people that that's
what it is it's like calling somebody up
on a prank call and when you when they
pick up you say hi I'm about to prank
you uh get ready for this prank this is
a prank we're about to do and here it
goes
so a little bit of a concept problem
there
once again uh I feel that the sweet baby
gang is secure and safe and we have
nothing to worry about Jeremy's razors
is offering a great deal that ends at
midnight tonight 40 off all razors why
the discount well I'm glad you asked a
year ago when Joe Biden tried to force a
vaccine mandate upon private employers
and some 85 million Americans the daily
wire told him where to stick it we sued
the federal government and we won after
a 6-3 ruling in our favor at the Supreme
Court the Mandate was dead together we
kicked the government's ass so on the
first anniversary of this tremendous
victory for all Americans the daily wire
CEO and God King Jeremy boring has
issued a special decree on the razors
that bear his name 40 off of all razors
that means you can get a Precision 5
razor with flip back trimmer shave cream
post shave balm extra blades and a handy
travel case for just 35.99 which is a
savings of twenty four dollars the Biden
Administration and its totalitarian
cronies were cut down and now we Rejoice
by drinking their tears enjoying our
freedom and looking damn good while
doing it now is your last chance to get
40 off all Jeremy's razors by going to
jeremy'srazors.com today that's Jeremy's
razors.com today now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
well if you've been listening to the
show over the past month or so you know
that we have returned frequently to a
discussion about the situation that
young men face in our culture and in
particular as it relates to marriage and
you know uh not only if you've been
listening to this this past week but if
you listen really at any point that I'm
a major advocate of marriage that I
especially encourage young men and women
to embrace marriage and family life but
there's been a significant cultural
shift away from marriage in recent years
with increasing number of young people
men and women giving up on the
institution altogether
and for men this shift has become its
own movement with its own name men go
their own way is what it's called and
the um the logic behind the movement is
that our culture is hopelessly corrupted
and the system is hopelessly rigged
against men and so that they're left
with no choice but to give up on the
system give up on Marriage give up on
the family and strike out on their own
focusing instead on their own
independence and sovereignty
as I've argued I understand the logic
I sympathize with those who are isolated
and lonely and feel that this is the
only path available to them but I don't
think that this that surrender is the
right response a man cannot give up on
what he was made to do and to be
to truly Go Your Own Way alone and
isolated is to give up on your duty your
legacy your ancestors your bloodline
your civilization your happiness
uh the movie Into The Wild tells the
story of a man Christopher McCandless
who went his own way to the extreme you
know burned a social security card left
his family hiked into the Alaskan
wilderness
and he died there alone and as he was
dying he wrote in the margins of a book
The Words happiness is only real when
shared this is one of the most essential
truths of human nature
most of us are meant to share our
happiness with with others
um and for most of us that's going to be
with a spouse and children
all that said
there are systemic problems with the way
that we approach and govern marriages in
our country and it is important that we
deal with and address those problems
which we which we usually don't
as one of the central points that a
great many men have made to me as
they've given feedback on the topics
we've discussed on the show in recent
weeks I've read many messages like this
one just choosing this one random says
Dear Matt absolutely agree with your
message about the importance of marriage
I agree that men should become fathers
and care for their families I even
generally agree with your take on Andrew
Tate but you talk about these things
while never addressing this these
systemic issues you push for marriage
but pretend that no no fault divorce
doesn't exist your message will fall on
deaf ears as long as you refuse to
acknowledge
the whole picture
now for the record it's definitely not
even close to true that I never talk
about divorce or no-fault divorce in
fact I've been talking about it for as
long as I've had a national platform to
talk about these things at all
but if I'm being teed up to talk about
it again I'm happy to oblige which is
why the cancer Lee for our daily
cancellation today is no fault divorce
now for those who aren't familiar with
the concept no fault divorce laws first
adopted by California of course and then
by every other state in some version
allow couples to break up their marriage
without any specific cause or reason
they don't need to prove that anybody
was at fault they simply tell the court
that they don't want to be married and
that's it
now in some states no fault desert
divorce is the only choice and at fault
divorce isn't an available option in
these states and the rest of the states
no fault is an option that can be chosen
among other options but but here's
perhaps the most important detail
in most situations
it only takes one spouse to file for no
fault divorce this means that one spouse
can break the marriage contract without
citing any reason except irreconcilable
differences even if the other spouse
doesn't consent
and this is where the gender disparity
comes into play the vast majority of
divorces are initiated by women Studies
have also shown that women are more
likely to get divorced after getting
promoted at work
achieving greater financial success
that's what the this you know the the as
their as their financial situation
improves the likelihood of divorce
becomes even even more significant
meanwhile women are far more likely to
make it to make it out well in the
divorce receiving alimony other forms of
quote-unquote spousal support
now in theory gender is not supposed to
factor into who gets alimony or how much
they receive but in reality it almost
always does even the New York Times has
acknowledged this an article last year
remarking on how rare it is for women to
be forced to financially support their
ex-husbands reports this quote according
to a 2019 study of census data by the
urban Institute a non-profit research
group half of the United States
households are headed by women on
average while National statistics on
alimony aren't tracked Michael Mossberg
a new york-based lawyer and the former
chairman of the American Bar
association's family law section said
that despite an increase in stay-at-home
husbands far more women than men seek
and receive spousal support
so women are more and more becoming the
Breadwinners in their families and yet
the family court system doesn't seem to
have noticed that alimony payments are
still doled out like it's you know 1953.
what this means is that a woman this is
what can happen a woman can marry a man
leave him for any reason she wants even
after cheating on him
and still take half the assets and be
awarded with an allowance from her
ex-husband in perpetuity
it's not only outrageously unjust but it
also purposefully in disincentivizes
marital Fidelity while incentivizing
disloyalty and infidelity and divorce
there are many reforms that should be
enacted to stop the bleeding here the
alimony system for one thing has to be
drastically changed most alimony laws
were created under the assumption that
most women would be Housewives and they
would be stay-at-home moms and most
divorces would be initiated by men who
are the sole Breadwinners in the family
and in a case like that where a man
chooses to leave a wife who was staying
at home to raise the kids and take care
of the house
um and and he decides that he wants to
leave it makes sense that he should have
to pay she structured her entire life
around the assumption that he would
provide for her financially so that he
so that he could you know so that she
can care for the children and he can go
to work if the man decides to go shack
up with a secretary or whatever
he should still have to provide the
support that he promised
but this doesn't describe
all or even most divorces in modern
America given that again most divorces
are initiated by women
and also most women have careers
there's no reason why a woman with a job
who decides to leave her husband and
break the marriage vows
should then be rewarded with a monthly
stipend from the man that she wants
nothing to do with
I think a fair system would require the
person who destroys the marriage to pay
regardless of the gender and it can it
be difficult to decide who's at fault
for destroying the marriage yeah it's
difficult but that's that's
what needs to happen these are these are
this is why these courts exist to make
these determinations
and if the divorce really is a mutual
decision which I mean it almost never
really is but if that's what they're
claiming then neither should expect an
allowance from the other if they both
have mutually decided this
but I think the reform to no fault
divorce is far simpler it should be
reformed by simply ceasing to exist
marriage is much more than a contract
it's a covenant
but to the extent that it is also a
contract it's hard to think of any other
situation in which a contract can be
broken for no reason by either party
without the consent of the other and
entirely without cause
you know um it's hard to think of any
other contract that would work that way
but by treating marriage this way we
have downgraded the marital contract to
something less binding than like the
agreement you have with your cell phone
carrier we've made it into something
cheap and worthless
and that's how it's therefore treated
when you make divorce easy
and for at least one party concerned
profitable you get more of it in fact
shockingly when you make divorce easier
and and more profitable for one sex at
the expense of the other you get a
greater number of the members of that
sex initiating divorces
you don't need a crystal ball to predict
an outcome like this
people respond to incentive incentives
if you incentivize disloyal selfish
behavior you get more of it
however if you make divorce difficult
and potentially costly for everybody
involved not for one spouse but both
then you've given couples an incentive
to find another solution for their
supposedly irreconcilable differences
and you've sent the message on a
cultural level that the marital vow is
Meaningful and important and not
something that can be just discarded on
a whim
now no fault divorce Advocates will
argue that the alternative
divorce without the no fault option can
tend to be traumatic and it could get
really ugly
but there's no way around that and we
shouldn't look for one
like divorce is an ugly thing no matter
what
a promise was made a vow was made now
it's being broken
that's an ugly thing there's there's no
way to make this ugly thing not ugly
besides no fault divorce doesn't
mitigate the trauma or ugliness of
divorce instead too often it simply
shifts the trauma so that one party is
made to carry most of its burden
and that is the problem
and for that reason and so many others
no fault divorce is or should be
canceled and that'll do it for uh the
show today and for the week we'll talk
to you on Monday have a great day
Godspeed
[Music]
the executive producer of the Matt wall
show is Sean Hampton our associate
producer is McKenna Waters the show is
directed by Mark Jones and Trey Miller
our production manager is Pablo vodowsky
second assistant director Austin
mckellis the show is edited by Jeff
Tomlin Our lead audio engineer is Mike
cormina our hair makeup artist is
Cherokee heart our wardrobe stylist are
Kristen galaraga and Elizabeth Fox
director of production is Mathis Glover
director of Technology Mark Herman our
camera studio and equipment manager is
Patrick Kennedy our lighting director is
Keith Duggan host production manager
Matthew Kemp episode art is created by
Morgan Pierce our executive in charge of
production is David wermis executive
producer Jeremy Boren the Matt Walsh
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2023.
hey everybody this is Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
Republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the Moon's turn to
blood but on the Andrew klavan show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew klavan
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the Republic with me Andrew Clavin
[Music]